mackay 6h30 du matin c'est le
cardiologue pédiatre seront au travail
avec sa collègue technologues mais
plutôt que de se diriger vers le chu
sainte justine où elle travaille
habituellement elles prennent la
direction de l'hôpital de trois-rivières
elle arrive dans ce qu'on appelle une
clinique itinérante une pièce aménagée à
l'hôpital où elle rencontre des patients
de la région durant une journée ou plus
ce qui veulent vérifier si la maladie de
kawasaki que je suis venu faire ici
c'est le même travail que j'aurais fait
à sainte justine et je vais éviter à
toutes ces familles lot de se déplacer
les spécialistes rencontre une trentaine
de patients par jour quatre jours par
semaine
elles se rendent dans différentes villes
du québec de gatineau à trois-rivières
en passant par amos sera plus facile
pour nous le devons avoir à se déplacer
à montréal les familles économise en
moyenne une centaine de dollars par
visite selon une étude
cela inclut les frais de déplacement
d'hébergement et de repas les personnes
qui résident à moins de 100 km de
l'hôpital sainte-justine peuvent
économiser jusqu'à 80 dollars par
consultation celle qui demeure dans un
rayon de 100 à 300 km économise en
moyenne 200 dollars les patients les
plus éloignés économistes plus de 800 $
par visite
mais là proches seraient aussi plus
avantageuse pour le système de santé en
général et sauves l'argent parce que le
fait que moi je vienne ici tout seul
comme coeur de la visite
les facturations font que si je fais une
équipe une visite la même journée ma
visite est pour payer le déplacement des
cardiologues ne coûte pas cher à
l'hôpital est en fait la rémunération ne
coûte pas cher non plus et c'est pareil
pour les technologues qui sont déplacés
mais en fait l'un dans l'autre ça crée
un énorme gain pour les patients une
perte une très peu de pertes pour
l'hôpital donc un bénéfice pour la
société
d'autres spécialistes au québec en
pédiatrie mais aussi pour les adultes
offre des services en région
les auteurs de l'étude affirment que les
établissements auraient intérêt à
s'inspirer de ce genre de modèle j'adore
avoir des études qui en fait vont cesser
les légendes urbaines donc on va savoir
de quoi on parle parce que c'est
important lorsqu'on essaie d'organiser
les soins avec le ministère con
les vrais chiffres devant mes yeux la
ministre de la santé danielle mccann
affirme qu'il s'agit d'une bonne
pratique et invite les intervenants du
réseau de la santé à sont inspirés et
c'est marie laurence de l'année radio
canada montréal